apple is currently holding 191.83
billion dollars in cash and that's seven
percent lower than the previous year
where they held well over 200 billion
dollars in cash
similarly microsoft is holding on to
137.98 billion
google is holding on to 121.08 billion
and amazon is holding on to 71.77
billion
unlike many of their founders these
companies are not only rich on paper
but actually rich in paper this begs the
question though
where in the world are these companies
stashing so much cash
and how do they ensure its safety
[Music]
well for the longest time apple will
store most of the money
in ireland in order to take advantage of
the tax benefits
in ireland it wasn't just apple either
ireland has been one of the most popular
choices for tech companies
since the 1980s but how are these
companies even sending tens of billions
if not hundreds of billions to ireland
on an annual basis
without any lawmakers noticing or taking
action
well the thing is these companies aren't
using dark portraiting or secret swiss
bank accounts or anything like that
tech companies send it over in broad
daylight and lawmakers are very much
aware of this
in fact this loophole is so popular that
it even has its own name
the double irish with the dutch sandwich
despite this
lawmakers can't do anything about it as
the entire process
is sketchy but nonetheless completely
legal
with that being said let's take a look
at how apple approaches the matter
the first step is opening an hq or
manufacturing plant in the desired
country
in the case of apple they opened a
manufacturing facility in the city of
cork ireland
way back in 1980 this isn't a shell
company or
just for the books location rather this
is a legitimate manufacturing facility
that eventually turned into apple's
european headquarters
today the location is home to 6 000
apple employees
and without research and development
logistics planning and
other business matters do occur here
where it gets sketchy
is the amount of credit these guys claim
we don't know the intricacies of how
exactly apple structures their
intellectual property
but the general understanding is that an
overweight amount of their intellectual
property
is stored in ireland let's take apple
music for example
apple europe may have legitimately
helped in the development of about
twenty percent of apple music
so ideally twenty percent of the revenue
from apple music
should go to apple europe or all the
revenue should go to apple north america
as that is still the main headquarters
instead though
what apple might do is say that apple
north america and apple europe split
their work equally
thus apple europe would get a 50 royalty
on all revenue from apple music
this way apple north america still gets
plenty of revenue to cover all of their
own costs
and even turn a little bit of profit
however
the vast majority of the profit would go
to apple europe
as they end up receiving a
disproportionate amount of the revenue
this is extremely smart as it doesn't
even look sketchy
it's not like apple is claiming that
apple europe did 100 of the work or
anything outrageous like that
apple's net income margin over the last
12 month period was 20.9 percent
so really apple europe only needs a 10
or 15
royalty to legally claim most of the
profit as you would guess
this strategy has worked out
phenomenally for apple for decades
don't get too mad at apple though they
have taken advantage of the strategy to
lower their tax bill
but they have continued to pay a decent
amount in taxes
in the last 12 month period they have
given up 14.4
of their profit to taxes not all of that
was paid to the us government
but it was paid to governments around
the world anyways
i think you'll be pleased to hear that
this loophole was just patched very
recently
given that this shenanigans has been
going on for decades
prosecutors have had ample time to think
of clever ways to put an end to this
they couldn't do anything about apple
sending over their money
but they could do something about
ireland allowing for this
you see not only were tech companies
benefiting from sending money to ireland
but so was ireland moving money to
ireland
simply means tech companies don't have
to pay taxes to uncle sam
but they still have to pay taxes to
ireland
though ireland was only receiving super
low effective tax rates from these
companies
when you have all of the top tech
companies shuffle into your country
you're going to nonetheless make quite a
bit of money with that being
said the european commission would
accuse ireland of essentially making
favorable tax laws
with the intent of drawing the attention
of top tech companies
the european commission would go on to
win this battle
which would successfully change the tax
laws in ireland
in 2015 legislation would pass that ban
the use of ireland for
any new tax schemes however companies
that were already using it got until
2020 to stop using it
aside from this the european commission
would also demand that apple pay 15
billion in european taxes
which is how much they apparently
avoided last summer though
apple would get this fine knocked off by
basically claiming
it's not our fault it's ireland's fault
fortunately for apple
not only were they able to slip out of
that hefty tax bill
but they didn't really mind keeping
their profits in america
apple was finally starting to pull in
large profits as
iphone sales skyrocketed in the early
2010s
as a result apple was no longer in a
rough financial position
like in the late 1990s and early 2000s
moreover apple was quite cash poor in
the u.s
which made it difficult for them to
complete acquisitions buy back stock
build new office spaces and so on the
terry on top
was that the corporate tax rate in the
us would be decreased from 35 percent
to 21 in 2017. as you can see
apple was likely going to shift more of
their profits to the us
anyways since the change in irish tax
policy
apple has kept most of their cash within
the u.s
but they are still using the same
loophole within the us
they found an island near new jersey
where there are no state corporate taxes
and that's where they're currently
sending and storing most of their money
so that's the basics of how apple moves
their massive cash pal
around the world while paying the least
amount of taxes
but that still leaves one more question
unanswered which
is how they actually store the cash once
they get it to where they want
apple could split their cash amongst the
top banks in the world
as these banks have such large deposits
that apple's 200 billion dollars
wouldn't actually be that hard to handle
for instance apple could select top of
the 10 banks in the world
like chase wells fargo and bank of
america
and store 20 billion dollars in each of
them these guys
often have trillions in deposits so even
though apple's deposits wouldn't be fdic
insured past 250 000 storing 20 billion
in each of them
wouldn't be that risky taking a look at
apple's balance sheet though
we'll see that they only hold a 38.016
billion
out of their nearly 200 billion dollars
in cash and cash equivalents
cash and cash equivalents is the money
that apple can come up with
instantly they don't need to break any
long-term interest plans or pull any
strings to get this money
this money is stored in corporate bank
accounts around the world
either in u.s dollars or the respective
countries currency
this can also be stored in the form of
short-term bonds that expire within the
next three months
in other words 38.016 billion is the
money that apple has in the checking
account
ready to be used to fund purchase orders
pay salaries run marketing campaigns and
so on and so forth
as we all know though checking accounts
offer no interest
or nearly no interest so like any
rational person
apple chooses to keep the money that
they don't plan on using within the next
three months
in something that offers less liquidity
but greater returns
which is marketable securities in total
apple holds 153.814 billion
in marketable securities split between
current assets
and non-current assets current assets
are simply assets that can be liquidated
within the next 12 months
while non-current assets can only be
liquidated within the next couple of
years
or even longer the most common type of
marketable security
is of course government bonds which is
basically when a company or individual
loans money to the government
and the government will pay them back
with interest over a set period of time
considering that the government can just
print money to pay you back
government bonds are regarded as a zero
risk investment
it should be noted that the government
has printed nine trillion dollars since
september 2019 though
so maybe they should scale back anyways
though government bonds are super safe
like bank accounts
they don't offer very high rates today
you're looking at a minimum of a 10-year
maturity period
to earn just one percent interest
annually another popular type of
marketable security
is corporate bonds as the name suggests
this is the same
as a government bond but instead of
loaning to the government
you would be loaning into a company
unlike the government though
getting your money back is dependent on
the financial well-being of the
corporation
you are loaning to because of this
individuals like warren buffett
are not the biggest fan of corporate
bonds with that being said though
loading to a company like amazon who
might be in need of short or
long term capital isn't that risky thus
it's likely that apple takes advantage
of corporate bonds which offer better
interest rates than government bonds
finally the last major type of
marketable security
is of course stock apple buys back tens
of billions of dollars worth of their
own stock
every single year so they no doubt store
a significant amount of their cash
in the form of apple stock at the end of
the day
apple is a cash cow who has so much
money that managing their money itself
is an art over the years they took
advantage of some loopholes storing most
of their money
in ireland but throughout the past
couple of years
they've decided to play it safe and keep
it mostly within the us
they simply keep their money in
corporate bank accounts loan their money
to strong governments and corporations
and buy apple stock when they can and
that's how apple manages their cash
today what do you guys think about
apple's massive stash
comment that down below also drop a like
if this video helped you understand the
logistics of big money
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then
i'm hari and i'll see you guys on the
next one
you